تتميز قريه مسفاه العبرين العمانيه
بموقعها المميز على ارتفاع 1000 متر فوق
مستوى سطح البحر على سطوح الجبال المحيطه
بولايه الحمراء ومناظرها الطبيعيه الخلابه
بالاضافه الى مبانيها القديمه التي تعود
الى مئات السن وعلى مدار السنوات الماضيه
نجح سكان القريه في جعلها نقصدا سياحيا من
خلال ترميم بيوتها القديمه والتقليديه
المصنوعه من الطين وتحويلها الى فنادق
صغيره عبد الرحمن العصيمي من هناك
والتفاصيل
[موسيقى]
ماسكات العبريين قريه تراثيه تمتد على قمه
جبل بارتفاع يزيد عن 1000 متر عن سطح
البحر وهي عباره عن مجموعه منازل تقليديه
متناثره في عشرات الازقه الصغيره المطله
على الاراضي المزروعه باشجار الليمون
والموز والحمضياتي والنخيل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مسبات العبريين واحده من القرى التي تقع
في ولايه الحمراء بسلطنه عمان والتي نجحت
في توظيف التراث لتتحول الى مقصد سياحي
يرتاده الزوار طوال العام هذا المكان
ينتظره الكثير من المشاريع السياحيه قريبه
[موسيقى]
اهالي القريه قاموا خلال السنوات القليله
الماضيه بترميم بيوت قريه القديمه
والتقليديه المصنوعه من الطين وتحويلها
الى فنادق صغيره
[موسيقى]
طبعا العمل التراث السياحي عمل متري
ومتجدد واحنا اخذنا على اعتقنا في البلده
نكون هذه اسسها اجدادنا انه يجب علينا
واجب علينا المحافظه عليها
وابتدانا باول ناس في عمان بفكره نزل
التراثيه او الفنادق التراثيه وهي عباره
عن بيوت قديمه
[موسيقى]
القريه التراثيه هذه اصبحت وجهه لاصحاب
المشاريع الصغيره والمتوسطه لاستيعاب عدد
السياح المتزايد
الفكره كانت غريبه نوعا بمنطقه جبليه ولكن
مع كثره همم المشاريع السياحيه الحمد لله
رب العالمين لكن اقبال كبير وهمم
حتى الحين همم صار الاقبال اكثر
[موسيقى]
في ديسمبر من العام الماضي 20 21 ادرجت
قريته مسفاه العبريين ضمن قائمه منظمه
السياحه العالميه كواحده من اجمل القرى
السياحيه وذلك خلال اجتماع الجمعيه
العموميه لمنظمه السياحه العالميه في
العاصمه الاسبانيه مدريد عبد الرحمن
العصيمي من ولايه الحمراء العربيه
عبد الرحمن العصيمي عبد الرحمن شوقتنا
للجوله السياحيه معك تفضل
اهلا سهام صباح الخير وصباح الخير على
نادين طبعا نحن ضمن جولاتنا العربيه في
السلطنه وهذه السلسله من التقارير هذه
الايام نحنا
موجودون في محافظه الداخليه ومن ضمن هذه
المحافظه ولايه نزوه وولايه الحمراء التي
قبل قليل كنا في قريه مسفاه العبريين طبعا
هذه المحافظه مدهشه للغايه بطبيعتها
وبيعتها وثقافتها وايضا تاريخها ولعل
تاريخ نزوى وضمن قلعتها على زميلي وليد
ياخذ بعض اللقطات هذه القلعه ال- ال-
الشهباء التي تعتبر من ابرز معالم سلطنه
عمان وتحديدا ولايه نزوى في محافظه
الداخليه التي استغرق بناءها اكثر من همم
يعني تقريبا مده طويله وتاريخها يمتد بشكل
عريق وكانت حسن المنيعا ضد الاعداء في
سلطنه عمان البرتغاليين
يعني جيوش كانت تحاول ان تدخل الى سلطنه
عمان كانت هذه
تقف يعني
في وجهها اولي الاعداء طبعا للحديث اكثر
عن هذه القلعه وتفاصيلها ينضم اليها محسن
ابو سعيد رئيس مجلس اداره شركه بوادر
العالميه استاذ محسن صباح الخير مو احوالك
احوالنا طيبه
انا اليوم لابس لبس عماني يعني لابس القمه
والدشداشه العمانيه
استاذ محسن لابس النصر
يلبس بالمناسبات الرسميه هذا الرسمي لما
تكون في حياتك اليوميه العاديه
طيب نتكلم عن اهميه هذه القلعه وانتم
كشركه لماذا قررتم الاستثمار بها كيف كانت
هذه هذه الفكره اخي عبد الرحمن
العربيه في قلعه نزوى طبعا فكره الاستثمار
هذه خطه الحكومه لتطوير القطاع السياحي في
سلطنه عمان
استثمرت استلمت شركه بوادر العالميه
للاستثمار همم في ديسمبر 2017 همم طبعا من
خلال هذا الاستثمار كان في خطه
كثير من تقويه كثير من الجوانب همم فيما
يخص الجانب الثقافي تراثي الحضاري في عمان
ماذا تطورتم في هذه القلعه
لجعلها جاذبه صياح الزور همم كان في
برنامج يا اخي عبد الرحمن
متكامل همم
يكون يلامس الزوار نحن عملنا اكثر من
17000 حرفه نفذناها في القلعه منذ
الاستلام
وايضا اذا جانب الفنون الشعبيه من اكثر من
300 تقريبا و30 مره شعبيه بالاضافه الى
تنفيذ المهرجانات كثيره
اخذت من
البرتغاليين والهولنديين هذا هذا مدفع
عثماني
طبعا هذا همم
وعلاقه عمان بالحضارات والشعوب الاخرى
ارتفاع تقريبا كم ارتفاع القلعه بالمناسبه
اخي عبد الرحمن طبعا انت امام اكبر برج
دائري في شبه الجزيره العربيه ومن اكبر
الابراج في العالم من حيث القطر والارتفاع
والقائد المردومه يبلغ ارتفاع هذه القلعه
همم 24 متر والقطر تقريبا في حدود 43 متر
والقاعده المردومه همم تتراوح بين 15 ليله
30 متر تحت الارض شكرا
يعطيك العافيه وشاهد الان احد الرحلات
المدرسيه ايضا على المدارس تقوم برحله
مدرسيه لتعريف حرص كبير ايضا من المدارس
هنا في نزوى نادين وسهام انه من يجيبون
الاطفال والطلاب ليتعلموا عن تاريخ نزوى
وتاريخ هذه القلعه
وتفاصيلها طبعا مبسوطين قاعدين يشوفوا
الكاميرا وقاعدين
يتناولوا وجبه الافطار
الاجواء جدا جميل
منطقه سياحيه بامتياز وحرص كبير من جميع
العمانيين وايضا الصيام من خارج عمان على
زياره هذه القلعه يعني عبد الرحمن انا
ساعطي عنوان للزيارتك لعمان يعني نزوى
بعيون جميله
وعيون عمان بعيون عبد الرحمن شكرا عبد
الرحمن العصيمي مراسل صباح العربيه